vous êtes content d'être sorti c'est
vrai mais c'est dingue à chaque fois que
je pose la question les gens sont très
contents de leur sortie on dirait qu'ils
étaient chez du bien quoi c'est vrai
pourquoi c'est un enfant vous étiez
combien de temps
5 semaines ah ouais quand même il y a 5
semaines et la semaine d'avant en fait
on en isolement pour préparer le prime
que vous aviez pas vu vos potes tout ça
votre famille donc à un moment flemme
quoi non après on s'est fait de nouveau
pote mais c'est vrai que
j'ai envie de voir la famille qui me
manquait très contente d'être sorti mais
sans déconner alors pour l'instant
de perdre non mais je te jure
mais chanter comme une mère de sa vie je
vais sortir j'en suis sûr non c'est vrai
en fait voilà donc tu étais contente tu
étais contente de sortir alors on va
voir ta prestation quand même qu'il y en
a voilà la prestation de Chris aussi
samedi soir ta chanter toi je retrouve
ça tu as chanté sur ta chanté sur quoi
déjà Mistral Gagnant Mistral Gagnant
exactement Jordan c'est pas mal merci
mais bon tu as fait exprès tu voulais
sortir
voilà c'est ça je suis bien compris
[Musique]
les gens tant qu'il y en a
te parler du bon temps qui est mort ou
qui reviendra on s'est rend dans ma main
tes pieds doigts
te raconter enfin qu'il faut t'aimer la
vie et les mais même si
le temps est assassin et emporte avec
lui les rires des enfants
et les Mistral gagnant
est-ce que tu savais que tu allais
éliminée ou pas du tout pas du tout tu
le sentais pas du tout toi tu te sentais
bien
t'envoie quelqu'un pas du tout faut
toujours en vouloir à quelqu'un quand on
sort
toi Christ a chanté avec mon ami que
j'aime beaucoup Vianney on regarde aussi
ta prestation regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui est sorti aussi
alors Chris pourquoi tu as participé à
la star acousta un rêve c'est un rêve de
gosse en vrai j'ai regardé à partir de
la deuxième saison et j'ai commencé à
chanter avec la star
et je pensais pas que ça allait
reprendre donc quand j'ai appris que ça
allait reprendre il faut que je
m'inscrive on m'a pris de cours m'a
contacté
de vente dans une grande marque de
téléphone c'est pas vrai
[Rires]
j'ai démissionné le jour où je suis
parti à l'hôtel pour tu as fait comme
dans la pub du Loto
[Rires]
passe-moi un iPad aussi
en vrai non même pas mais en fait j'ai
attendu ce moment qu'on tente vraiment
la peur parce que pendant des années
j'ai essayé de faire des choses dans la
musique c'est pas forcément évident il y
a plein de personnes qui veulent réussir
et là je me suis dit en vrai c'est c'est
un rêve donc merci beaucoup alors là ça
t'a ouvert des portes ou pas la star il
y a de belles choses il y a des belles
rencontres pendant l'aventure et on est
bien suivi et
en plus mais franchement et Diana Tiana
aussi Tiana est très sympathique je
trouve qu'elle a toi tu étais quoi c'est
ça et Chris moi je trouve qu'il a un
vrai talent il a il a un physique on le
retient tout de suite tu vois je peux
moi tout de suite je t'ai dès que j'ai
vu j'ai vu j'ai pas vu souvent mais tu
es tout de suite le voilà un des
premiers que je voilà que j'ai j'avais
remarqué aussi merci beaucoup je pense
que ça ça va aller ça va aller pour toi
j'espère en tout cas Tiana toi tu
connaissais même pas la star
je savais toujours pas c'était quoi
la télé
voilà ok
c'est trop bien donc toi tu fais quoi
toi à l'école ouais bah plus maintenant
[Applaudissements]
contrôle surprise
en classe dans quelle classe
j'ai eu mon bac en fait oui parce que
moi à 18 ans j'étais en 4e donc tu vois
on voit déjà qu'il y a ces deux salles
de l'ambiance non mais quand toi tu as
eu ton bac tu étais en quoi on STMG
ressources humaines
sur ce technologique migratoire
ressources humaines mais je vois pas où
est dans STMG c'est ça veut dire quoi
[Applaudissements]
elle elle était comme un iPhone tu vois
elle était chez lui tu vois quand il
travaille là-bas qu'est-ce que je vais
faire
je t'aime juste je trouve que ça sonne
bien moi c'est pas ce que c'est mais bon
j'aime bien je trouve que le nom de la
sonorité j'aime bien quoi non j'ai
retrouvé c'est bon alors c'est quoi
science technologique management
en fait c'est toi qui lui a dit mais non
on a fait le même bac
nouvelle domination STMG moi c'était
déjà l'époque et avant c'était cet été
là
pour me parler là les gars j'ai
l'impression que je vous ai convoqué
dans mon bureau bon j'ai vu pour ton
orientation non non mais bon en tout cas
bon on va voir votre élimination ça fait
toujours mal ça c'est rien moi aussi ça
me fait toujours mal c'est comme quand
je vois des chroniqueurs partir et j'ai
toujours un pansement au cœur je veux
dire regardez le premier élève sauvé par
le public
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le deuxième élève sauvé
et Nola
Léa
[Applaudissements]
les réactions de nos éliminer de Chris
et de Tiana mais de ses quatre
sur la crème de ma mère ils ont plus des
noms de biscuits dans la salle j'ai
remarqué Nico j'ai l'impression qu'il
est Intermarché
malheureusement malheureusement vous
avez été comme ça
qui va gagner cette cette affaire là
pour vous là
ce qui reste qui on peut mettre les
quatre finalistes alors qui va gagner
sur des conneries on dirait un catalogue
La Redoute
[Rires]
sur la vie de ma mère
c'est un truc de fou quoi qui va gagner
cette affaire pour vous
moi j'étais plus proche de plus proche
pardonisha mais il mérite tout ça après
c'est lui qui a voté mais qui va gagner
pour toi tout le monde dit que c'est
tout le monde dit que c'est Léa
alors moi d'après les statistiques je
pense ça va être Enola mais j'aimerais
que ce soit Léa même d'accord mais tu
penses que ça va être Enola mais tu
aimerais que tu sois Léa et Louis tout
le monde s'en fout d'accord oui on
dirait on dirait un mecs football
le premier épisode la première émission
et tout de suite je me suis dit ça va
être Louis et Léa en finaliste parce que
ils avaient voilà ils ont en fait ils
ont un patron
j'ai que regarder la première émission
et pour moi c'est les deux qui
ressortaient
aussi Christiana mathiana j'ai un coup
de cœur Georges je la trouve très darka
elle est très moderne aussi je trouve
que c'est la plus sympathique voilà je
dis la vérité et toi tu as tu imprimes
tout de suite toi tu vois on te voit ça
y est tu vois j'ai envie de sortir avec
toi j'ai envie d'aller casser le couteau
[Rires]
tu as découvert plein de choses dans
l'émission tu as notamment été à ton
premier concert c'est ça mais toi tu
avais jamais été un concert avant jamais
tu habites où en fait
le maire de veau c'est Jean-François
Copé
Jean-François Copé on dit souvent copain
comme Copé non mais c'est vrai
ouais mais non jamais pourquoi cette
cette défriser
je sais pas moi je me dis on peut les
écouter sur
téléphone tu sais que toi sans déconner
elle c'est ma sœur elle elle est comme
moi elle moi aussi je peux les écouter
sur Spotify
c'est quoi cette année va avec ton
ticket et fais là que tu as souvent des
des Anglais qui viennent te faire chier
au Stade de France tu vas voir des trucs
non mais c'est vrai c'est quoi ça
t'arrive et tu entends rien le gars tu
le vois sur écran géant et généralement
moi
vous serez chez moi je branche toi qu'il
faille à la télé je fais un qui fait
personne me casse la tête et j'ai pas de
ticket rien du tout à la limite jamais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donc en fait ton premier concert tu as
été mais ta directé ouais c'est ça
premier concert et mon premier Chocas je
sais pas si on dit ça comme ça
si tu faisais un concert est-ce que tu
irais te voir
[Rires]
et puis j'ai jamais vu comment c'était
le Zénith donc je me dis voilà je sais
pas quoi m'attendre donc voilà ça sert à
rien que je stresse maintenant en fait
tu sais pas si j'avance
je me dis non on était dans le public et
là dans 2 secondes je suis sur 16 trop
bizarre je sais pas
[Musique]
montrer le chemin
avec avec Slimane voilà qui était
toujours un sac à dos sur Youtube
[Applaudissements]
donc c'est pour ça qu'on l'aime aussi et
j'adore très gentil Slimane incroyable
c'est un amour de mec tes parents ils
ont dit quoi ils étaient contents ils
sont fiers de toi ils t'ont regardé
ils ont pas eu de mot de tête
[Applaudissements]
un grand frère et un petit frère ils
étaient contents
je vais essayer de travailler et puis je
vais essayer de sortir mon album et pour
faire un concert aussi ouais
à fond ils t'ont dit quoi ta famille ils
t'ont dit d'accord on y va à fond ah
ouais mais depuis il me le disent moi
quoi c'est eux qui m'ont incité à
m'inscrire sur la Star Academy
et c'est la finale de la Star Ac c'est
samedi salut les loups
qui chantent avec un orchestre
philatéliste
soit on dirait que les loups sur TF1
vous allez pouvoir voter pour Anisha et
Nola Léa granola petite écolier
événement ce soir dans la Star Ac Oreo
viendra nous chanter un titre
on va voir donc les quatre finalistes on
a une compil des Prestat des finalistes
Gilles Verdez je lui dis on a une compil
des princesses il me fait une tête genre
c'est un truc de ouf
[Musique]
qui a le droit
faire ça des mensonges et des bêtises
qu'un enfant ne croit rêveur
j'adore et alors c'est une petite compil
c'est très court si vous voulez voter
c'est maintenant
on va voir ah bah c'est Anisha
et moi je m'appelle wesh je t'aime
position Enola
Léa en 3 Louis en quatre voilà c'est
alors ça veut rien dire du tout mais
c'est le sondage des téléspectateurs de
TPMP voilà ce que vous à vous a plu voir
cette star ici autour de la table où
est-ce que vous avez rien à dire est-ce
que vous voulez vous barrer
moi j'ai trouvé une très bonne esprit
très frais ça fait du bien
j'aimais beaucoup tous ces petits gens
il y a plein de gens il y a plein de
gens qui croyaient pas au début et les
audiences c'est un carton je pense que
le casting est très bon là quand on voit
les prime franchement ça a de la gueule
et c'est ça qu'il faut mettre sur TF1
contrairement à d'autres émissions qui
en ce moment c'est une vraie mission
populaire qui fait découvrir des talents
et franchement moi je kiffe d'accord
merci au début sur le jury mais je
trouve que finalement les professeurs
ils sont vraiment
pris identité vraiment à poser
Jean-Pascal ça aurait été encore mieux
moi je moi j'aurais bien voulu un petit
rappel de 5 académique qu'on connaît moi
aussi alors moi j'ai comme Pascal
j'ai beaucoup aimé ce que je peux poser
une question à Chris que j'ai beaucoup
aimé la sacrifice alors Chris déjà je
peux te dire il me l'a dit pendant la
pub il t'emmerde
non mais je préfère te le dire comme ça
au moins tu sais au moins dans quelle
disposition il est venu hein voilà mais
tu peux lui poser ta question
effectivement vas-y la faussea c'est pas
un Tiana parce que c'est un peu gênant
franchement Chris moi je vous ai
beaucoup aimé mais la manière dont vous
partez je n'y crois pas une seconde vous
vous pouvez pas être heureux de partir
est-ce qu'on vous dit est-ce qu'on vous
dit de pas balancer en sortant genre
c'est un juste ou on m'a arnaqué et
cetera après j'ai pas dit que j'étais
heureux
c'est qu'en Fatou t'a quitté voilà ça
c'est pas être heureux ça c'est
le temps de revoir non en vrai je suis
personnellement je pense être arrivé au
bout de mon aventure ça peut paraître
bête on va me dire je suis peut-être
même de bois mais pas du tout je suis
pas là pour gagner c'est parce que
j'avais perdu confiance en moi
artistiquement parlant et
personnellement et en fait les profs mes
camarades m'ont aidé à retrouver ça et
juste j'avais juste envie de sortir pour
aller en studio et proposer mon univers
et c'est ça qui manquait et j'arrive au
bout de ma propre aventure donc il y en
a pas mal ici qui sont arrivés au bout
aussi
malheureusement il n'y a pas
d'élimination dans l'émission
on met les choses sur la table on s'en
fout on dit les choses voilà